(applause)
- I'm sorry.
I probably smell like static cling,
it's not my perfume.
It's sticking to me.
So I like drenched myself.
If you smell it, that's
not my Od Kelly Clarkson.
(chuckling) Yeah, it's static cling.
So how are you?
- I'm good.
I'm excited to be here.
- Yeah, I'm excited too.
This is such a cool project.
Before we get to that.
How is Denmark?
I hear it's like the happiest place ever.
Why?
- That's a good question,
we keep asking ourselves that.
I think it's a mix of things.
It's a great country.
It's a small country.
There's only like 5 million of us.
You can't really get
too carried away there
'cause everybody knows you
which I think is a good thing.
There's a high level of equality
and then there's these crazy things
like free healthcare
and free education and-
- See, it works, it works.
(audience clapping)
- It works for us.
I'm not-
- I hear y'all know how
to vacation well too
you take time.
- That's true, yeah.
We have the whole balance
between work and free time and life.
Work week is 37 1/2 hours
for everyone.
- That's like average like, oh-
- And then you have everybody is entitled
to at least seven weeks
of vacation a year.
- Wow.
- So that means that you can actually--
(audience clapping)
- That's why you're so happy.
- We're so happy, yeah.
- It's like, did you take many vacations?
- Yeah, as a kid my mom was a single mom
and I have two sisters
and we didn't have much,
but she insisted that we'd
go away at least for a week,
somewhere outside of Denmark.
We had this tiny little Fiat 600,
which is probably the
tiniest car you can imagine.
And then she would just grab
on our bicycles on the roof
and off we went to
normally it would be Sweden
or Scandinavia but we did one
trip once where we went to,
she wanted to go to Spain.
She was like, this is it.
But she also had this rule
that she hated highways.
She wanted us to see the
countries we went through
also cause the car--
- Why did she hate highways?
- I think also the car didn't
go faster than 60 miles
an hour so-
- She was slowly in denial the whole time.
- Every time when she hit 60
the car, was like (squeaking)
So there was that.
And then I remember I
was surprised by how,
we were going through the
Pyrenees, the mountains.
My mom is terrified of heights.
So I had, and so are my sisters,
they were screaming the whole time,
and so then suddenly the car broke down,
and I remember thinking I
was six or seven, I was like,
Oh my God, all the Spanish
men are so friendly.
'Cause say we had like every
time we broke down quite a bit
they would within two
minutes there would be a guy
they're helping.
And now of course I look back,
oh yeah, you have a 32 year old,
beautiful Scandinavian
girl standing there going,
"I don't Know what to do."
- Those Spanish men weren't
helping all the ladies?
Just your mom?
- Yeah, we did have a couple of,
I still remember also
that we had some visitors
in Denmark from Spain (Kerry laughing).
- She's polite, they helped her out.
- They were so friendly.
(continued laughter)
- Wait, so now you have,
is it 21 and 18 year girls?
- I have, oh yes.
I have my beautiful daughters, 21--
- So like that's kind of out of the house
kind of you're in to nest to try--
(applause)
Are you nervous about this scenario?
Like the guy situation, are you-
- Oh.
- 'Cause were you like
one of those guys that
you should be afraid of
your daughters dating?
(both laughing)
- Yeah, exactly, exactly that.
'Cause you have that thing
where sometimes you look back
and we like to romanticize
about those years
when we were younger or it were so great
high school, it was like,
there was nothing but joy
and then you start thinking and go,
well, actually it was pretty stressful
and you try to fit in
and you didn't know any,
I mean, all that.
So I think that was one of the things
when my kids and they're now 18 and 21
knowing that they had
to go through heartbreak
and all those things is devastating.
But of course then the boys, right?
And the first-
- Did you give them a hard time?
- No, the first time I was
introduced to a boyfriend.
I think I was more
freaked out than he was.
'Cause I remember I was like back then
when it was me I don't
know why I was terrified
of meeting parents but it is frightening.
- Do they date generally
pretty good guys though?
That's cool.
- So far so good.
I mean but then at the same time,
then you hear stories from their friends
and like there's, I mean,
there's a lot of frogs out there.
- Yeah, but I'm just saying
like, I think that maybe
you've done a good job
of representing to them
like how a man should treat you.
So maybe that's why they got good guys.
- I hope so.
(audience clapping)
- Yeah.
- I like that but yeah-
- No, that's good.
Just live in that fantasy world.
- I like yeah, I stay in my fantasy,
yes, it's all good
- It's all great.
Now let's all look at
his new Netflix movie
"Against the Eyes," so tell us about it.
I love movies like, is this like survival,
kind of like you're surviving a situation?
- It's based on a true story, you know?
- Oh, it is.
- I'm so proud of this
movie, I really love it.
And I've been looking to
do something in Greenland
for a long time, my wife's from Greenland,
so I've been coming there
for more than 20, 25 years.
And I found this book which
is just an insane, true story
of survival but also about companionship
and we have these, it's
about these two guys,
that get stuck in the North
Eastern part of Greenland.
They have to survive.
But also what happens
when you're under that kind of pressure,
what happens with your mind?
- [Kelly] Mentally.
- [Nikolaj] Mentally and he
just captured that beautifully
and we wanted to explore
this in the movie and we did
and then we wanted to shoot
everything on location
in the Arctic.
So we shot in Iceland and in Greenland
and it was tough, it was extreme,
it was everything hoped for.
So, when you watch the movie
and you see a storm or-
- It's like real.
- We were shooting in like,
I'd never done that before.
I mean, we were shooting on
these glaciers in Iceland.
We all had to carry a whistle
in case we fell into a
crevasse so they could find us.
And the one day-
- That's when I'm out (laughs).
- But I mean, the crew, they
all knew what they were doing.
It was great.
I felt safe.
Well, there was that one day
where there was this storm
and they kept saying
it's gonna get better,
but it just got worse, there
were hurricane force winds
and suddenly we were all called in.
Well, actually first we get this call that
this guy who was sitting
in a van had called in
that rocks were flying
through the windows of the van
but you couldn't make it
up and then we get a call,
we have to gather at base
camp to do a roll call.
So everyone had to be evacuated
and then they had to call everyone,
and then incase you weren't there,
they had to set rescue teams out.
So that was unusual.
- You were really, you were method acting
you like wanted to get in there.
- But the thing is it's what
we wanted 'cause we, I mean,
- It's beautiful though.
It probably looked beautiful
- And like shooting in Greenland
on the actual sea ice is
I mean you can't do that.
You can do everything in CGI
but you can't replicate
what it does to the actors
and to the faces and to the way you talk,
when you're actually
shooting in like 20 below
it's just, it does something special.
And then to, I mean, there
are so many things, like
obviously there's a lot
of, it's a true story,
this guy lived, there's a family.
We wanted to do it right.
We had a screening for the family
of my character two weeks ago.
And I was really nervous
because of course we are like
all the dialogue is something we make up
and we change stuff, it's a movie.
- Yeah.
- But they came out there
was like, they were so happy.
- Oh, getting that approval's cool.
- Yeah, and I was like,
how I got this beautiful
letter from a grandchild
and she was like this, she
was so afraid of this movie
because it was part of her identity.
That her great grandfather
did this and then like
and he was kind of this
secret in the family
and she wanted to keep
it, like keep it special
but she was very very happy
and thrilled, so yeah.
- That's so cool.
Wait, did you ever get
into like fantasy games
like Dragons and Dungeons and Dragons,
is that what it's called?
I always have men on this
show that love that game.
- Yeah, I love the idea.
No, I didn't, well, back
when I was in high school,
there was Dungeons and
Dragons was a big thing.
It still is.
- I didn't know it was a big thing,
but I've had several
actors like men on here,
it was like, "Yeah, I'm in a club."
I'm like what?
- I never got into that
kind of role playing thing.
But I wanted to be part of this group
and then they said, "Yeah,
we're gonna play this
and then we gonna smoke a
bit of weed, we get high."
And I said, I don't smoke.
I can't do that.
So they baked this cake for me
and I like cake.
- [Kelly] I love this story.
- So we came in and they were doing stuff
and I just saw this cake
and I just assumed it was all for me.
So I ate it all.
- No.
- And then they came in and
said, "Where's the cake?"
And I said, well, it
was for me, wasn't it?
And they got, "You ate all of,
that's a lot."
And I'm like, "No, it's
gonna be a fine, oh."
- It was weed cake, it had weed in it?
- It had like hash, hash or
whatever you call it, yeah.
- Weed but hash, yeah.
- Yeah, Yeah, I got a little weird.
- I Bet you got really into role playing.
- I actually literally (chuckling)
I got into character
better than ever before.
I was literally
(Kelly laughing)
chasing my friends through the forest
and they were like, "Stop it"
I'm like, "Ah"
and I don't know what the
character was, but it was intense.
Then we came back to the house
and I remember I was crying at one point
(audience laughing)
and then I was laughing and-
- The range of emotions.
- And then they said I
suddenly fell asleep.
It was literally like ah.
- Oh my God, you ate the whole cake.
- I ate the whole cake.
- Oh, and you didn't
know, that's not good.
Nicolaj, (chuckling)
that's so funnier though.